Hey Youtubers it's Charlie, and the BBC totally just released the official TV trailer for The
Doctor Who 50th Anniversary Episode
there was some drama surrounding a leak
the trailer I'll talk about that but
mostly we need to talk about our Top 10
Moments
as if there are only 10. I'm also doing
a bunch more videos with BBC and Nerdist
for the 50th Anniversary be sure to
SUBSCRIBE to get all those videos. I'll have
information in the description about that too.
but its TOP 10 time. So number 10 - The
Dalek Fleet during the Time War.
We've seen Dalek Fleets and Cybermen
Fleets in episodes like "A Good Man Goes
To War" and "Asylum Of The Daleks".
But we've never seen them during the Time
War. This is a lot like the opening scene
in Star Wars Episode 3, where they
basically just zoomed in and outta this
MEGA fleet. So it's going to be EPIC.
Number 9 - The Fez.
The Doctor has always had a really special
relationship with his neck wear
and hats but I feel like a fez is one of
the most famous hats that the doctor has
ever worn.
Number 8 - Matt Smith fliying around London
outside of the TARDIS.
There's actually some behind the scenes
images from when they shot this. It's
basically his 1st moment as the
11th Doctor. So it's a big call back
that episode.
Number 7 - The Zygons. So unless you're
a big fan of Classic Who or you watched
a lot of old episodes.
you'll really be seeing the Zygons for the first time. They've been referenced in more recent episodes but
they made their premiere during the 4th
Doctor's run - Tom Baker in "Terror Of The
Zygons".
If you remember the official images the
BBC has been posting the 50th
Anniversary
There's actually an image with a woman
wearing Tom Baker's scarf.
That's basically Beverly Cressman. She's
playing a young version of the Kate Stewart
character.
So it's a really nice callback to Tom
Baker's Doctor. Coincidentally David Tennant
has said that the Zygons are actually his
favorite Doctor Who Monster of All Time.
It's probably just a coincidence that there in here then, but that leads me to Number
6.
Number 6 - David Tennant in his TARDIS.
There are actually 3 unique TARDISES
In the episode
and there's still a lot of theories
about which version of 10 David Tennant is
playing
but currently the leading theory is Tentoo.
Number 5 - David Tennant riding a horse
out his TARDIS. The amazingness of
this is totally self explanatory.
Numberr 4 - Rose Tyler as the BAD WOLF entity. The glowing eyes let us know she's
going to be doing something very "Series 1"-esque
when she was in Super Goddess form
leaving clues for everyone. She also has
a line in the trailer that will be part
of my TOP 3 moments, but I'll talk about that
that in a second.
All my TOP 3 moments are John Hurt
moments. Obviously he is basically at the
center of this episode.
So Number 3 - John Hurt on Gallifrey.
We've seen Gallifrey in previous episodes but
because this episode is just so cinematic
and is done in such a big way, it's going
to be so much more EPIC than the
depictions we've seen of it previously.
Number 2 - The GIANT RED BUTTON.
One of the great things about a giant red button is that no matter what language you speak
or what country live in. There's nothing
like a giant red buttons that screams
"don't push me", which of course the Doctor
Who world means you totally have to push
it.
Right now the leading theory is is that
this is actually part
of "The Moment" or The Moment itself. Rose Tyler has a line in the trailer where
she says "The Moment is coming."
So I'm guessing that this is what she's
talking about. We can't totally debate this
in the comments, but we're going to get a
couple more clips the 50th
Anniversary before the episode premieres.
So we should all be looking for the Key
of Rassilon. And my Number 1 moment - John
Hurt's TARDIS.
Even people who have no understanding of
Doctor Who and don't really know what
the story is,
know that the blue box represents Doctor
Who. No matter what language you speak or
where you live,
it is so universal this symbol of the TARDIS. So anytime we get to see a new
TARDIS
it's an EVENT of the highest order.
Obviously the next event like this will
be when we get to see Peter Capaldi's TARDIS.
I'll be doing a separate video for that
be sure to SUBSCRIBE to get it. But let me
know what your favorite moments from the trailer were
and do you think that John Hurt will be
using The Moment in the episode?
And what do Queen Elizabeth's credentials
have to do with bringing the 3
Doctors together?
If you didn't see it before, I posted a
video earlier this week explaining a lot
of the videos that I'll be doing with
Nerdist and the BBC around the 15th
Anniversary Episode.
There's also special Livestream that's coming. There's a link in the description to all that
stuff. Like I said earlier, this trailer
actually leaked early on Friday. Originally
the BBC was going to post it on
television,
but it was sent to BBC Spain who posted
it to their Facebook page.
It was taken down, but of course not
before a thousand people ripped it and
uploaded it to YouTube.
So the BBC naturally just posted this
early. I'm sure somewhere Steven Moffat
is screaming just a little bit.
Next week on November 15th BBC will be
airing its next 50th Anniversary
clip during their Children In Need Special.
I have information about that right here.
You can click to find out. And you can click
here to get all my other Doctor Who 50th
Anniversary videos.
Thank you so much for watching, I'll see you
guys tomorrow for Walking Dead. High
Fives!